this is our final session of the first
day and it is our pleasure to have
Bhaskar bhattacharya speaking on higher
order theory of reforms go ahead thank
you thank you for the invitation it's a
pleasure to be here uh so title is a bit
over the top but you know I'm going to
talk about higher fluctuation theory of
random of subgraph counts in random
graphs sampled from graphons and their
statistical implications so this is a
joint work with only one Chatterjee who
is a graduate student at Penn from Dan
who was a graduate student in paint who
just graduated it's now at IBM Hans
vanity Jensen
so the talk will have three parts to it
the first part of the talk will be
probabilistic where I will talk about
the asymptotic distribution of subgraph
counts in random graph on models the
second part will be statistical where we
will try to use some of this asymptotic
distribution to estimate and construct
confidence intervals for subgraph
densities of the original population
graphene and the third and the last part
will be more combinatorial where I will
discuss some degeneracy issues of this
limiting distribution and the structure
of such degenerate graph phones and here
we will see some interesting connections
to things like quasi Randomness and
other other things
so this is a conference and graph limits
I'm sure everybody here knows what a
graph one is and why it's important but
nevertheless let me say a few words
about background and motivation and
start from the basic so the basic model
of a random graph which we all know is
the address training model where every
age is present independently with
probability P we call that GNP
so this model has been studied widely by
mathematicians but for modeling real
networks this is a bit simplistic so one
way to generalize this is to have the
inhomogeneous random graph model where
instead of having the H probability P
for all i j you have a probability p i j
for every age so the edges are still
independent and the probability of H
between I and J happens with pij so we
denote this by GNP where p is this
Matrix of probabilities
so several well-known Network models are
in this framework so if you take p2b a
block model you get the sbm
you know in statistics people study this
thing called the beta model where pij
has this logistic form e to the beta I
plus beta J1 over e to the beta I plus
beta J and several others
so the random graph on model is a
variant of this model where you replace
this matrix by a symmetric measurable
function so a graph one is a symmetric
measurable function and you can use this
to construct a graph in the following
way so the W random graph on N vertices
is obtained at as follows you generate
uniform random variables U1 to u n and
you put an edge between I and J
independently with probability w i u j
conditional on the uis
and we denote this by G and w
right
so graphones are Continuum analogs of
symmetric matrices and if you take it to
be you know various choices of the W
give you various well-known models if
you take the constant function you get
the dose training graph if you take a
block function you get the block model
and so on
so few words of background so we know
that double random graphs are dense so
you can easily compute what is the total
number of edges in this graph and you
know an easy computation will tell you
that the number of edges divided by N
squared will converge to the integral of
w over the unit square and we're always
going to assume this is positive so this
graph will always have order N squared
Edge so this is a dense graph
now there are many ways to make these
parts and the easiest way to do it is to
add this parsity parameter Row in in
front of this probability so the
probability p i j is rho n times wyuj
where you let Pro n Go to zero
so we will not talk about the sparse
regime even though some of the results
can extend to this pass regime I will
primarily focus on the dense regime but
I just wanted to make the comment that
you know something can be done if you
allow sparsity
okay so the basic statistical question
that you have given a graph from this W
random model is how do you estimate this
unknown function W so this is the
problem of graph one estimation which
has been studied extensively over the
last few years so here are some you know
papers which started this field and you
know this is led to a long line of work
so we are not interested exactly in the
problem of graphone estimation we are
interested in estimating subgraph
density so functionals of graph forms
like the density of edges the density of
triangles or homomorphism densities in
general so estimating densities of sub
graphs given a sample GN from this graph
on W
so this problem was started was was
started first in this very well known
paper of big Dolce and Levina and you
know they developed a way to estimate
these quantities
so I write down here explicitly some of
the subgraph densities which will appear
in the stock so the edge density we
already saw that
uh the triangle density is this thing
here you know w x y w y z w x z
integrated over the three variables the
density of two stars so two stars K one
two the this graph with one relief one
Central node and two Leaf nodes so the
density of that and for General H you
can write down the sumomorphism density
as the product of w over the edges of H
integrated over X
so our both is given a graph GN from
this model how do you estimate this
functionals or functions of these
functionals
and just quick question yes usually as
just to clarify motifs sometimes people
mean induced some crops by that I'm not
doing it okay but we are not kids yeah
that's good this is non-indians this is
just puppies yes so as I mentioned then
I might talk about a bit more in the end
if I have time that various interesting
Network functionals can be represented
as functions of subgroup densities so
one thing that people look at is the
clustering coefficient which is
essentially just the probability that
three people are mutually friends given
that one is friends with both of them
and you can write this as the ratio of
the density of triangles to two stars so
how do you estimate this quantity or you
know other related quantities
okay so let's try to uh see that how we
can do this estimation and what can we
say about the fluctuations of the
natural estimate so the sub graph comes
the homomorphism densities are nice
functions in the graphone space these
are continuous functions and so a very
natural estimate of the homomorphism
density is the is the empirical density
of H in The observed graph the density
of H in the graph ga
so let's set up some notation for that
so for a graph H we denote by x h of g n
the number of copies of H in The
observed graph ga I scale it properly to
make it into a density so th of g n is
going to be my density which is going to
be essentially the copy divided by n to
the VH well it's not exactly into the VH
but you know it's into the VH up to you
know some smaller order and I have a
multiplicative constant factor which is
just the size of the automorphisms you
know to take care of the various relay
buildings
so this quantity here is the empirical
is an estimate of the empirical density
of 18gn and a simple variance
calculation can show you that as the
size of the graph gets large this will
converge to the true density so your
normalization is
yes
if I asked if you would takes the T of
hgn or you define the T of x if you took
the natural T of H and GN which is a t
of H at the empirical graph one
so in the statistical language you will
say that th of gene is a consistent
estimate for th of w because it goes to
the two parameter as sample size
increases so the natural next question
is what is the distribution of this
estimator so this is a question in
itself from a mathematical point of view
but this is also an important question
because if we want to find a confidence
interval for this parameter we need
something about the asymptotic
distribution so what can we say about
that
so this quantity has been studied before
by various authors various people
several of them are here in the audience
so because
derived the central limits theorem for
tagn or xig and when H is Cycles or hr3
so some special types of H
for General sub graphs this was the CLT
was derived by Pharrell
there is a recent related paper by by
core enrolling where they don't look at
exactly this quantity but they look at
centered subgraph counts but the first
centered the adjacency matrix by the
mean and then look at the counts of the
triangles and they prove some clts
now all these results prove a central
limit theorem for this quantity so what
does that mean they show that this
quantity is approximately gaussian
okay so it turns out that in some cases
in fact in many cases the variance of
the gaussian can be zero so the limit is
degenerate
so this issue was first noticed and
studied in this paper by Hadley pelakis
and selectis what they showed that the
CLT can be degenerate and they had some
non-gaussian limit where H is a clique
so this paper is the starting point of
this work to study this degeneracy and
see its implications
so let's try to explain in a very very
simple case why this degeneracy happens
when H is just the edge so when H is
just the H everything is explicit we can
do a computation and we will see why you
have this so we're in the central limit
theorem has has variance zero and what
happens if it has variance zero
so let's start with by defining the
degree function of a graph one as just
you know the integral of w over one of
its coordinates
so if you look at the number of edges
this is just the sum over a i j but AIG
is the indicator whether or not the h i
j is present or not
so let's do a little variance
computation right so if I have to
compute the variance of this this is
going to be the sum of the variance of
the IJ plus the covariance
so what's the variance of a i j well the
variance of aij is nothing but you know
you compute X is squared minus a i j
whole squared and you get essentially
the density of edges minus the density
of edge squared just a computation of
the variance of AIG
and similarly you can compute the
covariance between aij and AJ aik so two
edges which share a common vertex are
dependent because of the uniform latent
positions they have right the edges are
not dependent but because they share the
same latent position they are dependent
so you compute what it is it's you know
a i j h a a j a i a i j a i k minus the
product of the expectation and this
turns out to be the density of two stars
minus the density of edges squared
so very easy
yes I may have missed it uh what's the
exact model you're looking at or the
vertices the vertex labels uniformly or
on a fixed grade yeah
so that's why we have this covarian star
otherwise this doesn't exist
yeah okay so if you put things together
we have a quadratic term coming from the
variance and we have a cubic term coming
from the covariance but these are the
constants here
so if you look at this expression and
you know that well the variance
therefore can be either in cubed or in
square depending on whether this term
here is zero or not
so what is this term here this term is
the density of two stars minus the
density of H squared so when is this
term 0 can this term ever be zero so
let's write this out so this is the
density of two stars minus the density
of H Square
so this is the square of the degree
function
the 2 Star is the square of the degree
function minus the degree function
squared
so this is nothing but the variance of
the degree function at the uniform point
so this can't be zero right whenever the
degree function is a constant
so whenever the degree function of a
graph one is a constant this term is
zero so the variance becomes N squared
from n cubed
so we say that a graph one is degree
regular if its degree function is
constant and this is if and only if you
know this is when the variance changes
from n Cube to N squared
and this condition is not something very
you know
like strict with lots of graph forms are
actually degree regular the
endostraining graph is degree regular
stochastic block models with equal block
size as a degree regular
so what happens if you are in the degree
regular case and what happens if you are
in The Irregular case
exactly so so it's Abba right yeah
exactly exactly yeah yeah planted by
section model I should say right more
more correctly
right so hardly it all showed that if
the graph one is not degree regular then
if you look at the number of edges if
you Center by the mean divide by into
the three halves so remember the
variance here is n Cube so standard
deviation is n to the three hearts then
there is a CLT this is the classical
regime
but this CLT can be degenerate and in
this case the variance becomes N squared
so standard deviation is n and in this
case the limit has a more complicated
structure so it has two components to it
a gaussian component and an independent
non gaussian component
so the gaussian component has variance
this which is not very important but the
non-gaussian component here is a
weighted sum of centered chi-square so
it's a square of a gaussian minus one so
these are chi-square random variables
whose which are centered and the weights
the weight CR are the eigen values of
the graph on W so the graph on you can
think of it as an operator the weights
are the eigenvalues of w not exactly you
have to remove the largest eigenvalue
okay so that's the limit it has a normal
part and it has a non-normal part which
is an infinite sum of centered
chi-squares weighted centered Chi
squares is that some finite some could
be finite for Block models but if there
are graphons with you know countable
Spectrum
so it can go but it's always countable
so
but then
if it's countable it's just abundant
variable well defined yes because the
variance is with the second moment of
Lambda ah yeah and which is always the
square integral of w yes that's good
yeah okay so this is what partly it all
showed for the case of Ages in fact they
they show the result like this for all
clicks of size r so they showed that if
something happens there's a normal limit
if that doesn't happen that is a
non-normal limit which has a similar
point
so in recent results we don't need one
advantages and we extended it so how
does this spectrum appear because the
Spectrum but usually it relates to cycle
accounts yes yes yes yes yes so yeah so
essentially so I can I have a slide in
the end to explain where this is coming
from but the moment if you look at the
moments of this quantity you can check
that the only Thrones that count only
terms that matter the cycle counts and
so that's why you have the Spectrum s
if there's anything else would be
smaller order so is it better moments
type argument or okay so they so this is
the point so actually it all proved this
result using science method and this
result using Metal Moments okay we don't
use a method of modes
okay so this is we extended this for
General age and so two things need to
change if we have to extend this to
General Age first the notion of degree
regularity has to be replaced by some
notion of H regularity so what is degree
regularity it is the density of edges
passing through a point x so this x is a
Continuum point but essentially the
density of edges passing through a point
x is a constant so for General H the the
philosophy is similar we look at the
density of H passing through a point but
now if the graph H is not a symmetric
graph it depends which point of H maps
to X
right so we can write down this more
formally as a graph on W is said to be H
regular if you first map the eighth
vertex of H to X and you look at the
density of H where the eight vertex is
mapped to its and then the average over
the choice of P
yes so it's not clear to me that that
would be enough I could imagine that
okay now you get some condition but
maybe sometimes you need to calculate
detail of X and Y by a fixing two labels
yes this is so this will be enough to to
understand the first order of degeneracy
so we have two layers of B generation
first when the central limit theorem has
these variance this variance comes when
two copies of eight intersect at one
point right but they could intersect it
but that is next order right is that
order you purchase
yes yes so we'll just go together a
second so we also need the two point
conditional home office we need that but
the definition of regularity doesn't
need the two point it needs the one
point but we will need the two point
breaking so next slide I have the two
point function here yes
so in other words the density of K so
this is what this means informally is
that the density of H where some vertex
of H is mapped to X is constant almost
and we have to be a bit careful because
the graph H is asymmetric so you have to
be careful which a maps to which X
so if the graph is actually symmetric it
doesn't matter what you map and you know
this this quantity is nothing but the
density of triangles passing through X
so look at the triangle functional to
integrate out the two coordinates Y and
Z this is the quantity that drives the
regularity
on the other hand if you have a two star
then it matters which vertex you
integrate with you which you fix if you
fix the vertex which is one of the
leaves then you get this degree Square
terms if you fix the vertex which is the
central vertex you get the degree Square
term and if you fix one of the leaves
you get distorted so in any case you
know for any graph you can compute this
quantity and that's my notion of
regularity
the other thing that has to change is
that the operator W which was giving me
the Spectrum needs to change to
something for General age so this has to
be replaced by what we call the
regularity operator which is exactly
what Christians said which W has to be
replaced by W X Y which encodes the
density of H incident on two vertices X
and Y so again we have to be careful
which X go which a goes to which X and
which B goes to which y
so I fix the vertex A and B of H and I
look at the density of H where a is
mapped to X and B is mapped to Y and
then I average this
so this gives me the two point
conditional homorphism density function
and again you know if it's a triangle it
doesn't matter which two you fix but if
it's a two star it does matter so for
instance if you fix X to be the central
vertex y to be the leaf or the other way
around you get this quantity here if
both of them are leaves you get this
quantity here you don't want to divide
there by the
yeah yeah so so I am right right so I
want to do that but I'm a bit sloppy
with constants depending on age
throughout so that I can fit things in
so this is Constable ideally that is a
factor of constant here in the theorem I
have because I did it like this so that
in the theorem it comes a little
differently you know what I mean so
ideally I want to divide by 1 over VA
choose two or something like that
otherwise you get six times otherwise I
get six times that yeah so the constants
depending on age are a bit under the
carpet just for space issues
foreign
it's informal precisely for the reason
just mentioned I am being sloppy with
constants but for any graph H whenever
the density true density is positive if
the graph on W is not H regular then we
have a central limits theorem X scale
into the VH minus half
which is what happens when you have two
copies of age intersect at one point
this variance is zero if and only if the
graph is regular according to our
definition so if the graph is H regular
which is when this quantity is zero then
again the limit has two parts to it
there is a gaussian part and there is a
non-gaussian part
the gaussian part is independent of the
London part and the lambdas here are the
eigenvalues of this operator w h which I
just defined in the previous slide minus
its largest eigenthand
okay and I am not writing down the
expressions of Sigma and Tau because
those are a bit messy but we don't need
them there are explicit expressions for
them so these results
just contacted their forces he's always
exactly so this is in all yeah it's
already
and you're writing that the multiplicity
of the word the type of values increased
by one but it's supposed to be an
operator right so isn't that just
meaning that you're throwing out the
large cycle balance but there can be two
eigen values which are which are largest
joint you know complete
between the two identities which are the
same it doesn't distribution okay I
don't understand
um
okay so let me say one line about the
proof of how this is done we can talk
about the later so the proof uses this
Machinery of generalizing statistic
developed by Jensen and nowicki several
years ago and what this allows you to do
is that we can write this sub graph
counts as what are called generalized
statistic and if you do projections onto
single variables UI you get the limit in
the regular case
if the limit in the regular in The
Irregular case if the limit in The
Irregular case is degenerate you project
on two UI u j so two UI UB and also on
the Y8 and that gives you the limit in
The Irregular case that's one line
summarizing you know proof but the
Machinery is very general and the
Machinery is so General that it actually
tells us sort of lets us understand
where these gaussian and these
non-gaussian variables are coming from
and it allows out allows us to prove
something much more
so what it allows us is to prove not
just single dimensional convergence but
joint convergence for multiple subgraphs
so let's say I have the number of edges
and the number of triangles together
what is their joint distribution we can
now do that
so let me set up the notation for it so
we will scale each of them correctly so
we will scale it like this if it is
regular this if it is irregular yeah
so the scale is essentially root n or n
if you think of it in terms of the
densities root n for CLT n for non-cnt
okay so I have a graph H and I Define
this this Center to scale version
properly centered by the mean and divide
by the standard deviation a v h minus
half if it is irregular and VH minus 1
if it is regular so this is the correct
scaling if I am regular or irregular and
so then the question is given a
collection of graphs H H1 to HR
suppose I have a graph on W which is
irregular with respect to Q of this and
regular with respect to the remaining
monitor so the most General setup what
is the asymptotic distribution of this R
vector
okay
so let me take a moment to sort of
convince you that why this is a somewhat
delicate matter then one dimensional
convergence because suppose I have two
graphs H1 H2 if both of them were
irregular then you know marginally they
are gaussian so jointly there will be a
bivariate gaussian so which is fine you
can explain it by the coherence Matrix
but let's say both of them are regular
then marginally there are infinite sums
of chi-square they have non-douchin
components but how do you explain their
joint distribution how to write their
joint distribution down right so you
need some machinery for that and for
this you know the language of you know
multiple stochastic integrals coming
very handy
so here is the result so you fix the
graph on and the collection of sub
graphs H1 to HR and you denote BT by the
standard Brownian motion on 0 1 and so
here is the result
so we have Z which is the vector of the
r sub graphs
it converges to this R Vector okay so
this terrible notation here this should
be all W's there is no n on the right
side this is the limit so this is Z1 h
of w and the first R of them you expect
them to be a multivariate gaussian so I
write this as a linear stochastic
integral so linear stochastic integral
is nothing but an infinite linear
combination of gaussians so this is the
gaussian part
and the other Q minus r parts has two
components to it there is an independent
gaussian component and there is a
quadratic stochastic integral so this is
an infinite quadratic form in the oceans
so there are various things to note here
so if you note that this function that
we are integrating this is exactly the
regularity function
so because we are in The Irregular
regime this the function is going to be
positive on a set of positive measure so
this is a degenerate unit
this function right here is is sort of
what comes from the two-point
homomorphism densities
and the quadratic components across I is
are dependent and also dependent with
the linear term and the dependence is
captured through this DBT
so these are nothing but writing
infinite sums in a compact way but this
is the you know a notation really for
explaining this limit but the theory of
generalizing statistic allows out to
allows us to write down what the limit
is for any finite collection so yeah
there's only one brand emotion so this
one down in Motion One Brownian motion
coming from this uniform variables sort
of so every vertex in the Continuum will
valued the Brownian motion DX and then
all your variables again
exactly exactly so if you think of it
like that then you can see the
dependence coming up
any questions
yes if you're saying that the brown
emotions are coming from the uniforms
what would happen if you would choose
your types oh that's a brilliant
question so if you choose your site
determistically I think you only have
this part this G so all the other ones
all the other ones are going to go over
we only have a multivari gaussian in
this part here
to explain to us a little says
statistics where you get the problems
right so I can I have a slide in the end
so I can come back to it to explain
where it comes yes but I remember that
yeah okay so that's the end of you know
the the probabilistic part so maybe I
can now go to the statistical part which
says that what what is the implications
of this results in inference so so I
want to find a confidence interval for
this subgraph densities right so the way
to do it would be to have some idea
about what are the quantiles of this
distribution
so one thing to note is that the
quantiles of these distributions are
unknown because they depend on W
but more importantly I don't even know
if I'm in the regular regime or in the
regular regime given a graph so there
are two issues here estimating these
quantiles but also telling me whether or
not I am in the regular regime or in The
Irregular regime
so to do that we have a two-step
procedure so first we set up a pseudo
hypothesis which says let's assume that
we want to test the hypothesis that W is
H regular versus W is not H regular
now this is can be done because you know
irregularity is essentially the variance
is zero and this variance which I did
not write down that is just a function
of sub graph counts conveniently
so I can have an empirical estimate
which is consistent
and I know that it scales faster than
root a
to this we can show so we can then do
the following I can say that if root 10
times this quantity is large I'm going
to reject my pseudo hypothesis
and then I'm going to pretend as if I am
irregular where the limit is normal and
the confidence interval is immediate
but what happens if the pseudo
hypothesis is accepted if it's accepted
then I have to estimate the parameters
of this non-gaussian component which is
more non-trivial which is like not
immediate at least
so this is where we develop in the
statistics World they call it the
multiplied bootstrap so we develop a
version of it for graphones and which
goes as follows so remember in The
Irregular regime the grant the eigen
values are given by this two-point
homeorphism function wh
so we can find an empirical analog of
this wh which is essentially an N by n
Matrix whose s and t at element is the
density of H with one vertex in s and
the other vertex in t
so this is the Matrix version of w that
you estimate from the sample and then
you look at the eigenvalues of that
and the result is that
we can show that if H is a graph you
don't really need connected but let's
say it's connected and I have some IID
normal 0 1 variables which are you know
independent of G then if you look at the
sum of this eigenvalues from the second
to up to the n
of Kappa s w s squared minus 1. then
conditional on the randomness of G only
on the randomness of this external
Randomness W this will converge to the
population distribution
so this is this is a way to estimate the
quantiles of this distribution because
this quantity here does not depend on W
it only depends on GN which I can see
through the eigen values and through
these external randomness
this is external Randomness right
and it's important to note just by
looking at a quadratic thing the
gaussian and the non-gaussian comes out
so that's also part of the proof so for
instance if H is just the edge this
operator W is just the adjacency Matrix
divided by n is nothing else so this is
just the eigen values of the of the
graph if you look at the eigenvalue
scaled by n and if you look at this
quantity for the edge case this is going
to be the estimated distribution
so how do you use it in practice well
use it in practice you essentially
resample this W many many times to find
a histogram of this quantity and you
report the sample point
since you're boosting here why don't you
just explain our posting so I just take
my craft and take it as the empirical
grapher I take many many examples of it
right you know
so why don't you take a piano you do
many many samples process then you get a
new distribution and now you calculate
say the track accounts however that's
the expectations from this yes simulated
distributions and you calculate and then
you look what percentage of your
distribution nice
expectation and you output that SRS so
that would be standard boost yes so
there are does it not work so I don't
know so it's something I think it would
be harder to show that it works this is
very easy to show this one so first of
all I think the proof of this would be
easier and secondly
I would have to think a little bit how
would you resample right because I don't
know also the uis
so it is one has to think a little bit
how to resample the W there are ways to
do it I think but it's not immediate
right it's not like iib you take any
sample right
so but this one is a very you know very
easy way of introducing external
Randomness and you can show you know
just by some whatever moment computation
that you know this is exactly this
distribution or you know we don't some
technique
yeah so your right hand side has the
same limiting distribution as the
fluctuations of your yes yes is it
independent of it is it equal to it if
you look at joint convergence right so
the joint convergence will require us to
use sort of the same gaussian for the
edge and the triangles I'll come to that
so this is only for one dimensional I'm
only doing the one dimensional
estimation problem first so I will I
will do the joint convergence in just a
sec oh but I meant I mean you're you're
adding extra Randomness here right so
how is that extra Randomness related to
the randomness that you see which counts
this is double this is
independent of the randomness of G I
understand what is your limit then also
independent of the limit you will get
for your age count
you mean if the limit doesn't depend on
whether you take gaussian C or any other
Center variable change the right hand
side has the same marginal distribution
as the fluctuations of the number of H
bars
so we we don't know that but that's a
good question yes we haven't looked into
that I see what it means you're mean if
I look at this one and the actual Town
basically yeah asking whether it's a few
squares are adding extra Randomness to
the right hand side or
distribution of this one and the
population version but that's a good
question yes
okay so let me summarize what is the
final algorithm for one dimensional
confidence X so if you have the pseudo
hypothesis if the pseudo hypothesis is
rejected I go for the classical interval
if the pseudo hypothesis is accepted I
go for the interval that comes from the
multiplier moveset and the theorem says
that for any graph H and graph on W the
interval that comes out of this process
will have power is 1 minus Alpha for any
density for the density th of w
Alpha is a pre-specified parameter which
is your coverage of the interval so
Alpha is five percent
Alpha is five percent
for all for all Alpha yes
right so all of these extends to Joint
confidence 6. so now suppose I have R
sub graphs and I want to find the
confidence sets for the r densities
together
so I will be a little bit like high
level here but what's essentially what
you do is you look at the empirical
versions of these two point homomorphism
densities and the empirical versions of
the one point homomorphism densities and
you have this pseudo hypothesis set up
for each eye and if depending on which
of them are accepted or rejected you set
up your Z hat
okay and you add this external
Randomness ZR Zs and zsdt so this is
what the name multiplied bootstrap comes
see you can add in these external
Randomness and now you have this Vector
you have this Vector so these are you
know what I just mentioned so this
Vector Z hat is z hat H1 Z hat H2 Z hat
h r
this you get all of that doesn't depend
on W it only depends on the graph G and
the external random and it has the same
asymptotic distribution of these gns are
all going to be W but the actual
distribution of the thing that we want
so how does your so your hypothesis
suggest you know exceptions will also
depend on iPhone right because that
hypothesis I have no I'll find it that
hypothesis I am doing that's a good
point that hypothesis I'm just rejecting
it at one
because I am this thing goes to 0 at
rate root 10 so it doesn't matter
asymptotically what constant I take here
nice yeah also like uh
hypothesis not regular
and also because you see this is large
that means it is I am in the uh of
rejecting H naught right so I think
right so now I think so if it is regular
it will be zero if it is regular it will
be zero and if it is irregular I will
reject this is large so I will reject if
it is irregular so it is 0 if it is
right
okay so let's Okay so that's the high
level summary of what the confidence set
is doing yes
so so you're rejecting when your
threshold uh uh variance is origin and
one
but then what did you also need to know
that that product actually tends to be
Infinity if you're
yes because I know that if it's regular
then this is zero this is a consistent
estimate this converges to you know
something positive under each one yeah
something positive yes is that something
positive order than one
no but it's something positive without
scaling not without scaling because I
see yeah that answers my question thank
you
but sorry just operationally you could
replace one by any point unfortunately
this is a this method
you could actually
so I know the distribution and scaling
right so no so when you replace it by
that but it's slightly more Hardware so
I'm sitting a little bit yeah but you
couldn't set up one it's a Signature Pro
okay
yes absolutely
okay so let me so that's sort of the
theory from a high level of what the
confidence interval is doing let me show
you some pictures to see this is
actually working okay so quickly some
pictures okay so this is The Edge
density of this is estimating the H
density so let's have a graph on which
is x times y so this graph one is age
irregular of course if you compute the
between function it's not a constant
so I can come I can run the algorithm
and I can compute the confidence
interval for the edge density 100 times
for a graph of size 300 generated from
this Square form
and I see that only four out only six
out of 100 times it doesn't contain the
True Value so I have excellent coverage
remember the algorithm doesn't know I am
regular or not it's it's running it's
it's you know it's doing this estimation
thing test and then estimate
so let's now take another example where
I am in the regular case so this is the
graph on corresponding to the bipartite
graph with two sides of size node so go
back to yourself you don't want to just
cover try to claim that you say your
probability of line is that is
asymptotically 0.95 yes so you would
expect this thing to be not too large
not too small neither is good so we are
getting pretty close here
okay so now let's consider a graph one
which is degree regular where you have
two blocks and the edges between them
come with probability half so this is
the random bipartite graph model and
this graph one is a regular you know
every eight density is quarter and again
you can repeat this on a graph of size
100 and you see that you know coverage
is pretty good
so that's for one dimensional confidence
it's let's try to do some confidence
hits for two parameters so edges and
triangles together
so this graph on is X Plus y over 2
again is neither age regular not not
triangle regular you can easily check
that
and so we can run this two dimensional
algorithm this two-dimensional
multiplier bootstrap and see what comes
out of it
so this is a heat map of 100 ellipsoids
100 confidence ellipsoids over graphs of
size 300. so what it means is the
intensity of a point is proportional to
the number of ellipses it contains
and again you see that this is the true
value and the true value is contained in
94 of the ellipses
you can see that there are some bad
ellipses of force but you know we have
still good coverage
so there are four possibilities here
triangle regular triangle irregular
triangle regular Edge regular so four
possibilities so we will do all the four
so this is the case where the graph one
is oh can't see the gray here
cool
you can see the gray here okay good so
okay thank you
so this is the graph on which you can
see there this corresponds to taking a
complete graph of size n over 3 and a
complete bipartite graph of size n over
three n over three this graph is age
regular every vertex is degree one part
no triangle regular because there are no
triangles here lots of triangles here
and again if you repeat this quantity
and if you run the algorithm great
coverage
let's take a graph on which is age
irregular but triangle regular so here
is one so this is slightly harder to
construct this is a graph which is age
irregular but triangle regular so I have
two complete tripartite graphs and I
joined them by probability half
every vertex CR has the same triangle
density
but here the edge density is different
so this graph is Edge irregular but
trying to regular and again good
coverage
and finally the last one we took an easy
example of a graph which is both agent
triangle regular which is if you take
the endocrine
which is of course regular for all
values of age and again the coverage is
good
so let me I don't know I'm almost out of
time but spend a little moment to talk
about the last part which is sort of the
combinatorial part where we will discuss
some degeneration with the link then
this is only going to take two minutes
so
I know that the distribution of the
number of copies can be gaussian but the
gaussian limit can be degenerate then
you have this non gaussian plus non
gaussian so if the graph on is regular
you have this scaling and under this
scaling this is the limit
so a very natural question is is this
limit always non-bedroom
right so with that is it true that this
limit also can sometimes be degenerate
so that would mean there's more to come
so the question is is the limiting
distribution of zhw always non-vision
so healthy Pelicans like it showed that
if H is a key
this distribution is always non-deter
there is nothing more to count that's it
so when we were starting out on this
problem we thought well for General
subgraphs this is also should be true
that this is it
so we try to give a general argument but
we were struggling so we started with
some very specific small subgraphs so
what is the smallest subgraph after
Peaks which is kind of regular that's
the four cycle
so we showed by an argument that is very
very specific to the four cycle that if
you take H to be the four cycle then the
limit is always non-degenerate
and the argument also worked for the two
star so K12 so we know four Cycles we
know two stars and we know please
so now there is the next step would be
so how much can we push this and what
can we say about larger graphs and so we
were trying a bunch of things and in
particular we wanted to see what happens
if you take the r star
a one three k one four and so on
and it turns out that if you have K13
that is a surprisingly simple example
which tells you that even the second
order limit can be degenerate
and this this example is very easy you
take H to be the K 1 3 and you take w x
y to be the bipartite graph form so 0 is
0 on the diagonal one one on the objects
and we know this graph one is regular
you can check that which means that the
normal limit is zero
we can check that this graph one is also
like second order degenerate so the
normal plus not normal limit that you
get from the second order is also zero
limits I showed in the theorem are both
zero here
right and so the question is what is the
limit so in this particular case you can
find the limit by an explicit
computation because this is a specific
example and it turns out the limit here
is a fourth power fourth degree
polynomial in gaussians in particular
you get the fourth thermite polygon
but sorry you you then also have scale
much different so this is supposed to
scale like you know VH minus 1 which is
supposed to be 3 or something or I
suppose much smaller scale yes
can you show me the original yes
this this variance is zero and he's very
interesting okay okay
so I'll come to a question of individual
degenerations in just a moment so you
can ask when is this the internet but
not this one and when is this legalized
but not that okay so that's the last
point and I will stop so I can align
with some questions of course because
this degeneracy is raised some questions
and
oh where is that okay so questions
so for which graphs H and which graph on
W is the second order limit degenerate
we don't know
okay we have no idea
can there be arbitrarily high order of
degeneration so can you construct a
graph h and a graph on W for which the
limit is arbitrarily ordered detergent
like up to order r or something
the question which one could just
pointed out that what if you know that
the limit is non-degenerate what is the
structure of w if one of the components
vanished if the limit in the normal
component vanishes or the non-normal
component branches so when is the limit
normal free which means when is the
chi-square limit degenerate
so for this we have a relatively good
answer but let's not go into that let me
sort of mention the question so when is
the limit normal so the limit is normal
If This Time Square component is
degenerate so an easy sufficient
condition for it is that the spectrum of
this operator is empty so that means
this operator is a constant function
this two-point homomorphism density
operator is a constant function
so of course if you take
W to be the endocrini graph form this
happens
but are there other graph forms for
which this happens so the question is
are there eight regular graph forms for
which the limit is normal then that
would imply that the function is a
constant the wh is a constant W is a
constant function s in other words are
there graphs which are not Edo straining
for which this limit is normal
and the conjecture is that probably not
so of course for edges it's not
but triangles this is some connected to
some result of forcing quasi Randomness
using triangles by reihar and Scott
and they showed any consequence of the
result says that for triangles the only
graph which is regular and as a normal
limit is the endothermic value
and so what happens for General sub
crops
so that's there and so I'm going to stop
there with the question in the end but
thank you so much for going over time
thank you
questions
okay thanks so much for the engaging
talk other questions yes
okay so here it is so
so where is that thing coming from so uh
this is for the edges just to be to be
easy and specific so I look at the edge
density minor H count minus its expected
value I write it as in two ways I write
I first add the conditional expectation
given you
and then I write the other term which is
the conditional expectation minus the
actual expectation
so this quantity is a conditionally
centered stuff
if you if this is essentially if you
condition a new and iib sound
so this is what always gives you a
central limit theorem a classical
Central
if you look at the the other term which
is the which is the condition which is
the conditional mean that quantity is w
u r u j minus its expected value so this
is exactly what they call a u statistic
this is an order to use statistic right
and if the graph one is not regular then
this will have variance 10 cubed
but if it is regular then its variance
becomes n square and this becomes a
degenerative statistic so then you have
to sort of go to the spectral properties
of U to you know find the link
statistics
the Brownian motion is always there so
the brownies essentially you can write
this quantity sort of you know as think
of these linear combinations you know if
you have a normal distribution right you
can think of it as you know normal zero
Sigma squared the you do the projection
onto the vertex u a so you look at the
conditional expectation given you a that
is the function value at the eighth
vertex so the normal will be integral of
f a d b a
so you know that's the Browning motion
the other one is again when you do the
projection on u a and u b two of them
and but it's the same Brownian motion
because they are coming from the
vertices
uh can I see your open problem side oh
yeah I think yeah
yeah for these uh the question that
relates to the uh forcing pair right
yeah is there a
General correspondence between the
forcing Pairs and these normal
set yeah so this is something I don't
really know so the question is that if
you if the two-point conditional home
orphism functions are constant
what does it mean about the actual
function W does it mean the actual
function has to be constant
so for triangles this happens to be
shown in independent you know different
work related to forcing by in this paper
and it's conjectured for any click
now I'm not sure you know whether you
know certain graphs you need to fix
three vertices so I don't know there are
lots of results in quasi Randomness I
don't know exactly how it fits into but
the question is can you find graph funds
for which the limit is normal even
though it's not Edo strain
or whatever I mean platform for which wh
is a constant graph form but that blue
is not a constant graph
okay so you what you want is for fixed
hair vertices you you want to have the
same counts for your age but the
original W is not and also I want to
have the degree
that
regular and pair wise regular let's put
it this way does it mean why that it is
actually fully constant
I don't know yeah probably for General
age it might not be but it's conjecture
for Clicks in the paper by healthy and
proved for triangles in a different
paper
yeah
foreign
[Music]
how difficult would it be if you go one
step further to show the process
convergence saying the square account
yeah so I'm a little yeah so that's in
the case where everything is in the
normal in the case where everything in
the regular regime is probably doable
but if you go to the regular regime I
don't know and this is something I mean
I don't exactly know the technicalities
to fill the Gap but I think the idea
what I said higher order graphing theory
in the title was to say can we find a
whole process converging some sort of
whatever that means of the
we have different dimensionals so
there's a bit more to do but
so that's great question yeah
there's a question here
oh
foreign
still bothers me that your test
um is not really necessarily practical
yes um is there a way for you to turn
that into a asymptotic
um uh procedure that we're able to do
testing and estimation at the same time
with given coverage so the part that
bothers you is because of the one yeah
okay so that part is because I am lazy
so that person you can yeah I can do
that because I I can't find the
distribution of that quantity and I can
make it better perfect but we are a bit
lazy so we did that like that the second
question is that do you have a sense of
a speedo convergence to
the limit in distribution okay so for
the gaussian case yes you know Adrian
and others have certain results using
Stein's method where you can find the
rate of convergence of the gaussian case
in the non-gaussian case I don't know
it's harder I think it is yes thank you
if not let's thank all that
[Applause]
thanks for participating in the first
day and there is a reception outside